here is a question i've been asked to do
and inequalities will come up in your
reasoning okay it was the last topic
yeah um there won't be weirdo like a and
b inequalities i think we'll deal with
that after the exam
but these will be in there and i'd
expect this is kind of a battle card
like this is
sort of you know eight nine out of ten
for the difficulty of an inequality
question you get so it's up there
okay um how would you do it now i asked
a few viewers you're coming in
um how you would do it there's at least
four ways to do this
okay at least i'm going to show you
three of them okay
and i'll let you decide which way which
way you think is the way i prefer
and which one you would prefer all the
methods i'm going to show you they're
all fine
they're all equally legit okay um
even if you like i said before even if
you settle on one method you're like i
love this method
it's you know my my child don't leave
don't touch it
you still need to be able to know how to
do the other ones right because
some questions will lean one way versus
another okay
so will they actually solve this in them
with with a question like this it'll
tend
not to be because those kinds of methods
and the method i'm going to show you
they're not like well-defined methods
like say the k method or use the cosine
rule
or whatever right they're all kind of
they overlap with each other
right they're not very well defined what
you may find is for instance if this if
part a was graph y equals blah blah blah
and then part b
is hence solve that that's about as
close as i would get
okay but otherwise you're free to choose
whatever way you like
so let's do method number one
and um you can call it a couple of
things i'm going to call it buy
regions okay but not just by regions
there's a couple of different ways you
can break up the regions
so the first way i'm going to do the
regions is um
with no algebraic manipulation okay so
i'm going to take this guy
and i'm not going to muck around with it
in a dramatic way so
i'm going to take that and run with it
okay
now when you think about regions okay
all of the work in in working out a
question by this way is not in the
algebra
it's in working out what regions you
should have okay and one of the reasons
why i assume this question was asked is
because
it's tricky yes are we graphing
i will graph but i'm not going to graph
it yet because i know a lot of you
are graphing a verse okay um and so i'm
going to show you how to do it whilst
other ways right now
remember i said the question is what
regions do i need to break it up into
okay now the first thing you notice is
you've got an absolute value
so that means you automatically got two
regions right
for absolute value of three x minus one
right
what that's equal to is two things
it's equal to three x minus one without
the absolute just regular three x minus
one for what region
when does it equal that
x is x is greater than a third right
more generally speaking it's when
whatever's inside your absolute value is
positive okay and what
the value that gives you that is uh x is
greater than
third okay so if x is not greater than a
third
if it's less than a third um you have to
have a minus sign in the front okay so
you'll get this or you could just switch
the order one minus three x
okay so i have two regions or two cases
if you like okay but if i'm not
altering the algebra of this
dramatically okay i actually have to
take into account not just the absolute
value
but this denominator okay it actually
makes things a little more complex
why
there will now be four well three
so think about this right the reason why
i'm thinking about the denominator is is
because if i have to do anything with
this
i have to multiply through by x right
but as you know because x is
unknown right could be positive could be
negative i need to say the negative case
and the positive case because
different things happen to the direction
of the inequality in each case
okay so not just is a third
kind of like a dividing point zero is
also a dividing point
right because when x is less than zero
when i multiply through the inequality
will change direction and when x is
greater than zero
it will not change direction okay so i
have
three regions three cases right so i've
got case for region one
which is x is less than zero
okay then i've got a middle case
actually i just parallel
which is it's greater than zero but
it's less than a third so it's in
between that little boundary
okay and then i've got my final case
where x is greater than the third so
obviously
it's positive so i can know what's going
to happen
all right so let's go about each case
one by one when x is less than zero
what's going to happen to the absolute
value okay um which of these cases is it
if x is less than zero which case is it
x is this one if x is less than zero it
must obviously be also less than a third
okay so that means i'm going to take the
minus case
when i get rid of the absolute values so
on the top i'm going to have this
x minus 1 all divided by x
less than 2. i'm going to leave that i'm
going to come back to it shortly
okay case 2 between 0 and a third um
it's still less than a third so i still
have
this case right
so far these look the same okay but when
you come over to this one
things are different right because now
that i've passed this boundary
x is greater than a third i don't need
this minus sign on the top when i get
rid of the absolute value
i'm just going to have 3 x minus 1 all
over
x so that's the 2. okay so now set up my
three cases
does anyone have any questions so far
yeah shouldn't you have a minus sign in
front of the x
for the first case on the denominator
yeah
why because x is less than zero
okay now the fact that x is negative is
going to factor in when i'm multiplying
through by x it'll change my direction
my
inequality but it doesn't add me another
minus sign here because then i'm back
onto this case
which is quite different right this is x
negative this one's x is positive
okay so just the one negative just the
one negative
okay i only really add in the negative
because the absolute value on the top
there's no absolute value on the bottom
right
all right now for reasons that i hope
will become clear in a second right i'm
going to start with case 3. i think it's
actually the simplest right
now x is positive so when i multiply
through by x
and have 2x on the right hand side what
happens to the inequality
nothing because x is positive all right
so 3x
minus 1 is still less than 2x
okay now it's just rearranged 2x over
here leaves me 1x there
and a 1 moves over so less than 1.
okay now what does this mean you have to
put together
the case with your conclusion
okay so this means which
part of x is greater than a third
satisfies my deployment which part of it
okay and the answer
is the part of x is greater than third
which is
also less than one okay so you've got
a number line you've got a third and
you've got one
right so i'm just interested in this
part to the right
and this is telling me well that part to
the right the one that you really want
is this part in between okay so from
case three
here's my conclusion i'm between a third
and one
okay right let's go ahead with this one
now
just like in case three x is positive
okay
so when i multiply across the direction
of the inequality does not change
right so i've got this
so far so good now i might as well
actually on this line
expand that
that okay all right now let's see where
shall i put this
i guess i'll take the 2x over and
also take the one over
and then i can divide by minus five
is that okay does it all check out
it looks alright now again i have to
combine
my case with my conclusion here's my
case so i'm only interested in
this area between zero and a third okay
that's what this case means just forget
about the rest of it
which part of this part works answer
the part that's greater than a fifth all
right so that's i don't know
somewhere like that okay so greater than
a fifth so now i've got this little
region in here which works
okay so from case two what i've got is
this i'm between
a fifth and a third is that okay
right let's finish up last case first
case
okay because i think it's the most
confusing
because x is negative here right when i
multiply across
the inequality flips around okay so i'm
going to have let's
expand this so minus three x plus one
when this x comes over
the inequality changes is that all right
yeah okay let's take the two let's swap
the two x and the one over
i keep doing the same thing right i've
got minus five x
and then i'm gonna have minus one
then i mult i divide by minus five this
looks familiar doesn't it
okay now hold on a second what does that
mean okay because x is less than a fifth
x is less than zero ah yeah okay so
remember
the way that i combine my case and my
conclusion
here is i think all right
when i look at this case and solve this
algebra all i'm thinking about is
the region to the left of 0 that's all
i'm thinking about
and when i answer this it'll tell me
okay which part of this line
of this section works and the answer is
all the parts of this section that are
less than a fifth now how many parts of
it are less than a fifth
answer all of them right so even though
this is more restrictive
sorry sort of more restriction depending
on your perspective okay
then this what i really take is this
okay
so my conclusion from cases one is
x is less than zero